you
hi everyone is Jerry there's an
instructional Queen trap out of the Fort
Knox variation of the French defense
that is capable of catching even a
grandmaster opponent I'm able to say
this because I experienced that
firsthand
I had a grandmaster opponent making
inaccuracy early on I was aware of the
trap and I was able to take advantage of
it
now I feel that it's instructive because
from the variation itself
there's an important strategical concept
to take away from it and we also see
highlighted from the trap itself the
importance of move order especially in
the opening why it's a bad idea to bring
the Queen out early the importance of
calculating accurately and in many cases
deep enough and also the power of in
between moves and discovered attacks so
let's see how that all works starts off
after E 4 we have e 6 French defense d4
d5 Knight c3 this knight's deployment is
irrelevant he can also play to d2 since
after D take C the knight is recapturing
Bishop d7 the beginning of the Fort Knox
variation and the idea behind it is to
do what exactly the strategical concept
behind this variation is to give up the
light square bishop and then make sure
you have pawns around on light squares
to compensate for his loss but we don't
enter that we don't go down that road
instead we get to see in inaccuracy by
black right away Knight f6 this is not a
good move what's better is to play the
Queen Knight here and only then deploy
the knight to f6 then black would be in
a position to meet Knight takes with the
Queen Knight recapturing but it's very
easy to mix up the move order Knight f6
and now we capture the knight what would
be best at this point is to recapture at
the pond but I believe most players is
black would be recapturing with the
Queen keeping the pawn structure as is
but after this recapture the black Queen
is sin
we lost if you'd like to pause the video
see if you can figure out how white
should be responding from this position
okay here's the solution
it's Bishop g5 the queen is running very
short on squares and I think many
players as black would be thinking
Bishop g5 is a bad move because there is
this potential in between shop Bishop
takes Knight and now what do you do is
white if you're recapturing with the
Queen well this isn't good material is
balanced and what you have to show for
this smashed open pawn structure not a
whole lot
similarly capturing the Queen this is
even worse you're down a piece as white
if the white bishop moves away so too
does the black bishop if you capture the
bishop black captures your Bishop lack
is up a knight in this variation the
trick here is to meet this in-between
move with an in-between move yourself
Queen to d2 a very very easy move to
miss in your calculations if you're
playing on the black side the Queen is
defending the bishop of course she's out
of the line of fire of the bishop on f3
and she is in directly controlling d4 if
now Queen takes d4 we get to see now a
discovered attack with Bishop b5 the
king is in check the queen is dead now
the best continuation for black at this
point would be to actually capture on G
to allow the Queen to be captured the
bishop takes the rook from this position
the material is actually balanced but
black is still having a difficult time
because this pawn is under fire white
also has a lead in development and this
bishop runs the risk of maybe getting
captured if something like c6 King to e2
if the bishop is going to c4 excuse me
if the bishop is going to d5 we can see
c4
he's running short on squares White has
all her pieces working now there's g7
coming under fire in short
this is not the road to go down from
this point right here if as black you
are recapturing on f6
you are officially losing your queen
after this Bishop to g5 move